bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de l'europe et nous
consacrer à la sécurité des jouets
depuis cet été et le rappel par mattel
de plus de 20 millions de jouets c'est
un sujet qui préoccupe les européens
avec nous pour en parler
la députée européenne allemande evelyne
gebhardt bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne socialiste depuis 13 ans et
vous avez fait dernièrement une
proposition de résolution pour une
nouvelle directive sur les jouets
dangereux avant d'évoquer ce sujet
quelques chiffres clés en europe 75 %
des jouets vendus viennent de chine plus
précisément dans la région du gong gong
qui est devenu l' usine mondial du jouet
en france 160 millions de jouets sont
vendus chaque année
en 2006 la répression des fraudes a
contrôlé 5500 jouer en magasin 600 ont
été envoyés en laboratoire et lors des
tests 18% se sont révélés dangereux
certains un jour et passe donc à travers
les mailles du filet tout de suite
sébastien maillard nous explique ce que
fait l'union européenne pour protéger
ses consommateurs
et
il ya une action interne en europe
qu'est la directive de 1988 sur la
sécurité des jouets ça a consisté à
rapprocher des 10 l'action des états
membres pour harmoniser les normes de
sécurité et faire en sorte que bien
jouer fabriquer puis circuler librement
dans le marché européen
la contrepartie c'est qu'une fois que ce
produit est à demi fou msref turque ihh
qui répondent aux normes et donc c'est
pour ça qu'on a mis en place mais la
très tardivement depuis seulement en
2004 le système qu'on appelle rapex
système d'alerté rapide et ça consiste
bien à ce que chaque état membre notifié
à la commission européenne
les produits souvent déjoué en
l'occurrence c'est aussi ça peut être
des produits électroménagers
enfin tout ce qui est hors alimentaire
ou pharmaceutique qui eux ont la propre
les agences bien ces produits sont
notifiées à la commission qui les
relaient aux autres états membres et on
a ainsi une vision globale de tout ce
qui est dangereux et en circulation en
europe
pour améliorer la sécurité des jouets
l'union européenne a donc harmoniser les
normes existantes dans les différents
pays à chaque état membre
ensuite de s'assurer qu'elles sont bien
respectées tout de suite je vous propose
de voir ce reportage dans les rayons
français peut-on faire confiance aux
jouets qui remplissent nos rayons
questions clés à la veille de noël
cet été une grande marque a dû rappeler
plus de 20 millions de jouets jugés
dangereux pour la santé des enfants à
baqem bien sûr que ça a pu passer à
travailler à travers les mailles du
filet cela fait bien sûr oui mais bon
c'est bien pour rappel parce que comme
je dis j'ai vu les dimanches mandaté
vision là les perles qui était qu'avec
la peinture est nocif pour être vendue
en europe un jouet doit en principe
respecter des normes strictes de
sécurité
il ne doit pas comporter de produits
toxiques ni de petites pièces que les
jeunes enfants peuvent avaler
on a eu un problème sur un produit
premier âge il ya quelques temps c'est
un produit qui était en fin de vie des
bandes velcro se détachait dont on a
donc envoyé une lettre à nos clients en
demandant d'affiché c'est peut-être on a
reçu une centaine de retour de produits
et bien évidemment on a soit échangé le
produit soit rembourser le produit au
consommateur si les normes sont fixés
par la commission européenne s'est
ensuite aux états membres d'effectuer
les contrôles
quant à jouer dans do est détectée dans
un pays le système d'alerté rapex doit
l'empêcher d'être vendus dans les autres
états membres
en 2006 près de 1000 produits dangereux
ont été détectés 30 % de plus que
l'année précédente
l'exemple à quoi perdre est un très bon
exemple on a d'abord eu une information
de la part du professionnel qui
indiquait que c'est pour certains de ces
produits n'étaient pas conformes
présenter un danger
on l'a diffusé à l'ensemble des états
membres et l'ensemble des autres états
membres
en même temps quasiment instantanément
ont pu vérifier aussi sur leur
territoire si il avait le produit de
commercialiser
sous la pression de l'union européenne
la chine à supprimer 750 licence
d'exportation depuis cet été des
centaines de fabricants chinois doivent
rénover leurs installations et un
système d' alerte devrait être mis en
place sur le modèle de rapex evelyne
gebhardt on parle de plus en plus de la
sécurité des jouets est ce parce qu'ils
sont plus dangereux qu'avant je ne crois
pas qu'ils sont plus genre dangereux que
qu'avant mais il y a de plus en plus de
jouer qui sont produits deux sortes très
différentes et il est vrai que les
contrôles sont plus faciles à faire de
nos jours donc on trouve plus de
produits qui sont un problématique sur
la vue 75 % des produits vendus en
europe viennent de chine
en tout cas pour les jouets est ce que
ce n'est pas justement plus difficile de
les contrôler c'est plus difficile de
contrôler bien sûr parce que son produit
en chine
le sigle c'est est un sigle qui est
contrôlé par les entreprises elles mêmes
donc il n'ya pas de contrôle externe
alors là vous parlez du marquage ce et
es qu'il protège les consommateurs
ce n'est pas un sigle de protection des
consommateurs et c'est ça le problème
parce que beaucoup de gens croient que
c'est le cas et moi ce que je demande
c'est que ce sigle cs devienne un réel
sigle de protection des consommateurs
cela signifie que les règles soient très
bien agencé que l'on ait des normes très
claires et en même temps qu'on ait un
contrôle externe sur la validité de ses
comptes dès les normes et de la
réalisation des normes alors si on
explique aux consommateurs que le
marquage ce et ne veut plus rien dire en
quelque sorte est ce qu'il ne faut pas
tout simplement supprimée en créant une
autre maman non parce que le marquage
cieux c'est quand même un marquage que
les entreprises met elle-même et elle
certifie avec de cette manière là que
ces produits sont sécurisés c'est très
important parce que s'il ya un problème
qui se pose si il y à des intérêts qui
doivent être payés un moment c'est à
notre entreprise de le payer mais pour
le futur
il vaudrait mieux avoir un sigle commun
européen sur de protection alors on l'a
vu
la sécurité de ces produits des jouets
préoccupe beaucoup les consommateurs je
vous propose tout de suite d'écoutés la
question d'une cliente rencontré pendant
ses achats bonjour alors ma question
comment faire pour améliorer encore plus
sa sécurité des jouets surtout pour les
jeunes enfants
alors nous avons demandé en tant que
parlement européen la commission
européenne de faire une revalorisation
de l'actuelle directive sur les jouets
qui existe déjà mais qui est sûr le
l'état des connaissances des années 1988
la commission européenne a promis de
nous proposer un texte pour la révision
de la directive jouer pour le 7 janvier
donc bientôt nous aurions préféré que ça
vienne beaucoup plus tôt parce que ça
fait quatre ans que nous le demandons
mais maintenant avec la discussion
actuelle ça mis la pression sur la
commission européenne et maintenant ça
va venir et je pense qu'on va avancer à
grands pas alors certains professionnels
du jouet se plaignent de la complexité
du système beaucoup de normes s'empilent
s'empilent les unes sur les autres
je propose tout de suite découpé et la
question des présidents de vtech france
voilà une entreprise de jouets chinoise
une question pourquoi au lieu de
renforcer des normes existantes ne pas
essayer de renforcer plutôt les
contrôles au moment de l'arrivée des
produits sur le marché européen
en effet nous devons inciter les états
membres à faire plus de contrôle à
l'importation pour que l'on soit
vraiment sûrs et des produits que l'on
rentre bien sûr on ne peut pas tout
contrôler mais on doit faire des
contrôles beaucoup plus approfondie
quand il s'agit par exemple de la
protection des enfants sur les jouets
par exemple et diront il ya peut-être
d'autres domaines où on peut faire un
peu moins mais là où c'est vraiment très
important d'en faire plus et de mieux
valoriser les possibilités de ce travail
de communication entre les différentes
douanes
européenne pour que si par exemple à
malte ont fait un test sur un jouet on
ne soit pas obligé de le faire aussi à
hambourg est plutôt qu'à hambourg ont
fait un test sur un autre jouet et le
système d'alerté rapide
rapex est ce qu'il faudrait également
l'améliorer je pense que c'est un très
bon système que les états membres
devraient mieux utiliser encore c'est à
dire de bien former la commission
européenne encore beaucoup plus vite sur
les pros pour les pros but sur les
produits à problèmes pour qu'il soit mis
encore plus vite dans le système rapex
pour que les informations passent dans
toute l'union européenne
une dernière question au bout du compte
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on peut compter
sur l'union européenne pour protéger les
consommateurs
oui là où il ya un manque c'est en
général ce sont les contrôles c'est la
transposition du droit dans les états
membres parfois aussi donc que les
règles soient vraiment implanté et soit
connue aussi dans les états membres
mais ça on peut l'améliorer je pense
qu'on peut vraiment compter sur l'union
européenne parce que nous avons fait
quand même ces derniers temps des normes
quand même très très stricte
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'entreprises se
plaignent régulièrement le des normes et
encore une règle que nous devons
accepter mais c'est pour les
consommateurs et les consommateurs sont
notre priorité
evelyne gebhardt je vous remercie c'est
la fin de cette émission si vous voulez
des informations sur la sécurité des
jouets et si vous voulez notamment
connaître la liste des produits notifié
à la commission européenne
vous pouvez vous rendre sur le site de
rapex vous pouvez également retrouver
cette émission sur le site de public
sénat publicsenat.fr
à très bientôt pour une nouvelle
émission de l'europe hainaut
plasan où chaque semaine durant 45
minutes sur public sénat c'est un homme
ou une femme politique qui se prêtent au
jeu serré le plus réactif possible des
questions réponses avec moi sur le
plateau plusieurs journalistes de la
presse écrite pour relancer d'inviter à
l'écriture au fond des dossiers mais
également aller chercher la petite base
il s'agit d'animer le débat bille mais
face à nous présenter par michel
grossiord c'est tous les mercredis en
direct à 18h45 sur public sénat